hey good morning everybody we are here
first very special good morning to you
good morning
to you good morning
uh the best movie we watched uh in the
last 10 days um actually that's not true
at all oh my god
not even in the top 10 i don't think but
it is a movie that was long awaited uh
by us at this desk because um it's been
teased for two years and we finally
finally got to see if it lived up to the
hype um i'm here with danielle
and lon and we are talking our honest
trailer for morbius as well as um uh
some deleted scenes as well as uh some
questions some q a so keep those coming
in the chat teasing you with next week's
uh honest trailer and doing very special
unboxing i hope this is what i think it
is um you guys this might
be very disappointing very disappointing
if it's totally unrelated oh thank god
it is uh what we have for you today um
that we just got delivered right before
the show
is
hashtag sponsored but not but we're
gonna do it anyways
we got more bsg fuel for yeah
we're doing it we got the gamer fuel
that only morbius craves um
how is it not in a boat now what this is
i don't think they're legally allowed to
tell you what's in this
well only if you go to a central
american cave system
it's got real bits of
bits
in every
bite is this a powder or a gummy i'm not
sure
the flavor is plasma um so you know you
you know you love that flavor yes energy
focus endurance and reaction
now does the does the what is the g is
the g4 gamer in this or is that is that
what is that why it's g fewer yeah all
the g's all right every g and every
reaction channel it's got every reaction
number one in the hood g
that's good that's good more oh wait is
this creatine what is this it's got a
little bit of everything that morbius
craves
i think should we all do it or should we
just have somebody do it as like a
control like i'll be a control group
i'll do it i think we all have to i i
definitely want to try some of this
morbius brandon i'll do a bump
no wait we gotta you mix it right you
mix it with something yeah uh to be
determined um ryan just leave it on this
wide angle and we'll talk about morbius
while uh get us something yeah so please
to pour this potion into i guess water
water uh milk how about milk yeah i feel
like it's a very old man move to be like
orange juice like it's metamucil yeah
yeah
amazing we're going to keep regular
using morbius mix it with madima tap
have a party as excited as i am to uh to
really get morbed um the film
uh very incomplete feeling movie to me
yes felt like it was uh a a bit of a
movie left over from several other
different movies that got ground into a
fine powder yeah
it was very like cut to pieces uh a lot
of plot lines didn't really go anywhere
a lot of characters kind of didn't get
their resolution um as lon was saying
earlier most of jared harris's lines
were adr'd in he's he's in very little
of the film and almost every line of
dialogue he delivers you can tell
was like altered during post so my
theory is that his role was like totally
different the way they shot it and then
the version we're saying i think he
might have been he's he's a good guy in
the in the finnish movie i think he
might have been a villain a villain's
turn in the original yeah well because
i'm wondering um something that we all
notice as well is that there are
obviously scenes in there with um milo
where you can tell like it's coming off
the back of another scene yes um like
there's that nightclub scene i love how
we say this as though any of you watched
it um
by the way we're just casually having a
conversation like oh yeah every movie
you know how oh oh my god
i've been morphed much like we're trying
to find the scoop uh if there's like a
recommended scoop in size and much much
like morbius
immediately losing control of his bat
power
spencer has spilled the g fuel all over
himself now is this is this one is this
a safe dose
looks like a mech
it definitely looks like something that
i smoked i mean no not me oh no no there
we go so do you do the full
the full shebang or is it just uh let me
see the container
the package must have okay surely
morbius has some more guidance call
jared harris morpheus wouldn't just
leave us in the dark like this all right
well so what we want is
wow do not exceed recommended dose it
says that right on here yeah yeah this
is one sir it's okay you take it
one of those one scoop you pour it in
here you fill it with water you shake it
up but we're not all then we'll mix it
we'll know we'll mix it and then put it
in the cups all right there we go just a
little yeah get in there
spitting on some more bees just a little
bit of powder some more uh so where are
we talking about morbius yeah we're
moving right here i'll mix it up in here
well yeah so it was one of those things
where um
in the nightclub scene when he goes up
uh confidently to the uh to this blonde
patron and she's like i think i've seen
you somewhere before and then he starts
beating up all the dude bros it's like
it feels to me as though
there must have been a scene where maybe
pre-elixir um before he got the ooze
that he had had a moment where they had
met and like maybe like he talked to her
or she was nice to him or something then
the dude bro is like beat him up
like more stuff that um established why
he went full
goblin mode yeah there was no
explanation for why he became an evil
vampire there was one line where he's
like i suffered they should suffer too
shake that
and yeah there was no moment of like
fun in the movie where like they're both
vampires time to like see what it's like
to be a vampire out in the town except
for that one club scene yes that ends
with a vampire murder off camera which
is a bold choice yeah for your family
there's a lot of off cam like like hear
a scream from just below
there's a lot of that kind of thing yeah
um all right uh all i can think about is
getting into this g fuel so let's let's
play the trailer and we'll uh we'll stop
and start as uh as we see fit
a long delay
a medium-sized delay a little bitty baby
delay and one more
delay for good measure
audiences
am i going to lose a foot we're all
going to be footless
this is how it happens
cheers
oh my god
we didn't i did not i will say for the
record i did not even put in a full one
of the i left a little bit off the top
because i figured you know we're you
know i didn't want to make it too potent
i think i'm going to be playing
counter-strike in my mind
this video
does this is there adderall in this did
i allowed to put out no
they they yeah they changed one part of
the chemical so it can't technically be
called adderall um
can i just say
purely in terms of flavor it's it's not
bad i i thought it would be it's not bad
but i would love some more water to like
mellow this out a little bit
yeah i'm also like one of those people
that waters down juice i'm drinking
unsweetened i mean i feel like i put i
partnered one scoop of that in here and
then i filled the rest of this with
water so it it this isn't even a serving
no it's it's about one serving
i'm gonna need to like fully change
clothes you are you're
so dusty
just tell people you're a baker you're
going to attract gamers from the
neighborhood they're going to start
following you around
[Laughter]
destiny 2 servers are going to be like
where did everybody go
this whole neighborhood
all right all right people everywhere
are demanding
stop playing the morbius trailer every
time i see a film it's been two years dr
michael morvious at your service no
i love how they had varying degrees of
this is a spider-man movie in them you
can see the desperation rise as they put
more and more vulture and more like
daily bugle and like random pictures of
tokyo he doesn't say that exact line in
the movie does he he goes he goes i we
are venom and then the guy freaks out
and then he doesn't say dr michael
murphy is at your service he's like
something else he says something else
he's like nah that's cool man i'm just
kidding i'm a dog yeah he says a
different line in the movie which is
like i you can't fool me i've seen that
scene a hundred thousand times
yeah i don't know what you're trying to
pull here with this alt take yeah that
was brutal what were we saying they made
two sonic movies in the time it took
them to make between the trailer and the
debut of morbius while we waited for
more bees and also top gun maverick
which still like we're still waiting
next week uh we've gotten two different
sonic the hedgehog movie yeah yeah wow
uh gotta go fast all right keep going
morbius meet michael morbius a doctor
living with a serious challenge being
jared leto his search for a cure will
take him from the cave of wonders to his
much hidden very secret experiments i
wouldn't go in there if i were you
that shot's very funny that's very funny
it is really funny but it's also like
how do you
how do you how how i don't want to get
too like huh but it is very much like
this is a hospital why were they
suddenly like we need a bat tube we need
a bat tube
also did he invent the bat like i've
never seen is that a thing that other
labs have
the question is what was the bat harp
that he took to the cave of wonders what
was what was that thing that he had was
it a bat net is that a bat net he catch
a bat bats yeah
reasons got the fields kicking in
reasons undetermined okay you're turning
into martin scorsese let me ask you
something about when you get it back
what do you need what do you need with a
bat what are you going to do with the
bat get your bunch of bets right now um
what do you think he's a raging bull
he's a boxer he's also a bat
what i love about his whole medical
career is that they as a throwaway line
say that his inventions have saved more
lives than penicillin well it's
artificial blood artificial blood yeah
but if you ask dr michael morbius he's
like i don't give a [ __ ] i'm just trying
to save my own ass with my rare blood
diseases
there's a very confusing sequence where
he we see him at the
the as the film calls it the nobles
the nobel prize ceremony he's there he's
in the suit he's got the sash on he's on
stage but then they cut to a scene later
and he's talking about how he skipped
the ceremony so that he could be with
his patient right we just saw you at the
ceremony you didn't you got up from your
chair and then they cut away and then
they were like he's in trouble yeah i
guess
again in the original cut he gave a
speech where it was like
artificial blood's bad for some reason
and the nobel prize is bad and now
people are upset with him that all got
removed from the end i do kind of wonder
like what the speech was because my my
speculation was that he got up there and
was like he pulled one of those like um
awards or nonsense and you do it for
like the love of the game and you do
you do it because you love music and
all of this about the batsman yeah
wasn't it like fiona apple or someone
who got up there at one of those awards
ceremonies and was like this isn't real
and none of this is real yeah yeah yeah
yeah so i feel like he full fiona yeah
or he sent up a bat to accept on his
behalf
yeah and then he had yes so he does
secret animal experiments um in this
completely open office plan plexiglass
room and there's a uh there's a moment
where like you can see nurses walking
down the hallway yeah in the background
and one of them even comes in while he's
doing his secret experiments is like dr
marvius the girl is that you're also
treating next door is going into account
yeah at some point it's like he's doing
this in a public hospital like wait is
this like saint ignatius and there's a
patient down the room you're doing top
secret crazy mad science in here hey
look you know uh some people have ant
farms some people have fish he has a bat
tube i assume that that's it they're
just like oh he's like wacky uh dr
michael jordan he has a bat tube i guess
this is a good time to also talk about
the production design and the whole film
which we do talk about in the audition a
little bit but it's a good deleted scene
yeah it's very it's just very odd like
his lab there's another lap there's a
lot of scenes where it doesn't they're
they're in rooms that don't look like
the room they're telling us they're in
like you're in a hospital room but this
is this is a utility room that you've
put a bed in a and a machine that goes
ping in right like a bat tube yeah
relentlessly through the whole movie
like the interiors just don't kind of
match even the rich guy like when we go
to the rich guy's penthouse it's like
really weird and cramped and closed it
looks like a set that they decorated to
be like eccentric richard what city are
we in right where are we i don't know
are we in new york it seems new york i
think it's supposed to be new york yeah
because the subway that's there is a
subway yeah but yeah oh yeah yeah good
point all right let's keep watching more
fry on a boat while his girlfriend is
asleep doesn't count babe we're in
international waters
jared leto plays a misunderstood genius
who's way too cool to accept the nobel
prize see there he is and then it cuts
rejects noble prize so of course he
thinks this character is based on his
real persona there's something
quite nice about that and the intimacy
of
sharing
who you are
uh with with with audiences yeah plus
one thing jared leto's a bad actor per
se he just seems like pretty
insufferable to be around on set like
because he demanded that he would stay
in crutches to go to the bathroom and it
was taking so long that they convinced
him that he could do a wheelchair yes
that's just as annoying when you're in
you're in morbius sir sir you're in
morbius yeah no it is i've never thought
that he was like a bad actor uh it just
seems like uh um he is
uh himself is a bad actor when it comes
to the things that he does on set like
he's like not i don't i wouldn't want to
be well yeah i would i'd like money but
it's
but if you're someone who is like a
professional actor it's like
and he brought a bat again was he
sending people bats like how was he what
was he doing on set he was doing uh he
he wanted to pretend like he really had
bloodiness or whatever the
disease was that he had so he made he
stayed in um in the crutches and or on a
wheelchair when he wasn't shooting
and i believe if you look at that clip
we just showed too he it sounds like he
was also doing the voice kind of like
even that's what he says in that
interview like um is he says that he's
like it's so refreshing because he's
such a chameleon he always has to really
disappear into these roles but finally
the role of dr michael morbius was
something that really reflected
himself from who he was on the inside of
course which is a misunderstood genius
who's uh too cool for the nobel prize so
yeah
sounds like a good hang all right keep
playing the guy who drinks money and
he'll get all the things you'd expect
except kovid like sonar
that's about that
[Applause]
never seen them
you know badass that's a thing
that scene right there another like is
this movie finished um where he gets
blown away by a strong breeze uh during
a chase and he stands on the edge of a
building and tyrese just tells him to
freeze
and the chase is over yeah he just stops
again like from a later scene you
realize oh he he can fly he just doesn't
know it yet so like i guess we're
supposed to interpret that it's not a
breeze it's his body trying to fly away
but he doesn't know that that's in his
power set because there's you don't get
an instruction manual when you become
morbius well i mean the problem is that
not enough people in the audience had
started clapping yet
so that he would be able to be able to
play yeah i just it just doesn't play
because you're just like what is why is
there a magic purple it was a long chase
with with lots of fighting uh up until
that point and then he gives up yeah it
doesn't it doesn't it's one of those
things where it's like there was
obviously more to this and then we're
just we're only seeing this like weirdly
abridged
version of it that doesn't really make
sense love it all right good stuff you
love this movie
with your mind
this is where it gets really
off the rails are we sure these are bad
things but these powers come with a
catch now he's thirsty for blood and
instead of eating animals that actual
bats eat he'll go straight for human
juice forcing us to watch him go to town
on a blood bag every few minutes of
screen time
well this is just like camp when i found
out where they hit the capri suns
but mikey won't morb alone meet a
supporting cast whose backstory got cut
for time like tyrese a bland fbi agent
whose robot arm only appears in the
trailer
that's insane that's crazy that's such
an insane detail to never never follow
up on it no good and he he did like oh
you know your um your invention of
artificial blood saved my life and he
has like the scar and all of his other
stuff yeah this time um you know uh in
the wars uh
one of the worst we're in like we're
always in them
um but so that's another thread where
they just didn't they left that out
there and i'm assuming because at some
point it's one of those things where
they'll be they'll build him up so that
maybe
his character is uh good at punching
yeah let us know in the comments if
we're um really missing out on the the
deep lore of tyrese the robot arm
policeman because yeah they were they
did not give us money it's definitely
laying groundwork for for something yeah
yeah like he's supposed to be coming
back in the sequel is like a guy
[Laughter]
with an arm no doubt he's a nice guy
with an arm but also just a a strange
choice or maybe this is why he took it
but like tyrese is the straight man in
the in the funny cop serious cop
psychotic i'm not al madrigal is his
partner okay
that's a state is a pretty well-known
stand-up playing the partner uh
and yeah like they've given him a thing
like he believes in vampires and he's
like he's got holy water with him but
they never it's there's no
follow-through well people are take
really take their being vampires in
stride in this building oh my god yeah
you know that's good that's a that's a
huge thing to talk about like people
find out they're available there's very
little shock there's always just like
like even on tv they'll be like and the
latest in the string of vampire murders
like that's a big you would be surprised
sir you're in the sony universe this is
still a big deal to you you're not in
him you know
you'd be like well there's vampires
okay i guess venom went to a rave so
after nobody that's the thing well we
get to it later but nobody knows about
venom
do they know about venom they mentioned
san francisco yeah they say like the k
but that's like in in the context of
like it's a police case that like there
was a serial killer in san francisco
yeah
well also even if you knew about like
the creature venom would you know his
name is venom like how would you know
that you would definitely know uh
renegade journalist eddie brock right
now renegade
the brock reporter
like the black toothy monster who'd been
terrorizing san francisco baby but i'd
already be like oh you know venom that
guy yeah and that guy venom sorry about
venom sorry
you would you know uh
cletus mcdonald or would that is
yeah
uh venom i don't know if you'd know by
name that seems very very familiar
all right let's keep going my hit canon
he's jax martine a doctor whose only
interesting aspect gets punted to the
sequel
[Music]
anna a child morbius puts into a coma
and never visits again it's very busy he
gets very busy with morbing
that was like
yes banana seeing the sequel
um yeah that was a that was incredible i
kept expecting her to wake up or him to
wake her up but we never see her again
and she's stuck back in his lab and
morbius clearly has other better things
to do after that point he's he's being
he's a wanted man he's on the run he's
got to fight his she's your child she's
just passed out yeah she's still in that
coma um yeah
yeah
yeah she's with you all at the end of
breaking bad they're just sleeping
forever in our collective imagination
have we been watching too many we have
been because i was like hoping that
there would be a little evanescence in
there or something for me yeah like a
little evanescence but yeah just a taste
all right keep going justice for anna
hope she's feeling better
jared harris a skilled thespian who
lends the fill much needed gravity and
he's dead
watch the dr morbo take on the 11th
doctor milo matt smith acting with the
freedom of someone who realizes they're
in a train wreck so they might as well
have some fun while it goes totally off
the rails
pause what is
where's his fortune from because he's an
orphan just like um that's another thing
just like morbo as a kid yeah
i believe it feels to me as though they
make several um
comments that make it sound like he's a
con man like when um morbes goes to see
him uh in the penthouse for the first
grown ass time and he's like oh well
there's a bunch of like russian dudes
here because i guess i was too lucky at
cards and mobs is like well that can't
be a coincidence and then when he cons
his way into um the jail like it makes
it seem like maybe that was part of what
he did was that he started using his
intelligence to con money out of it he's
like a fake poker player he's dan
blitzerian yeah we know he's not like an
heir because he's in like a group home
with morbius as a kid who by the way
they only knew each other as children
for a week or yeah
best friends friends for life
we both have bloodiest bros
like normally in this scenario you'd
assume he's just like had wealthy
parents who died or something yeah but
like we know it's not that so it's got
to be that he made the money
himself yeah so i think conning and
gambling would probably be the smartest
guess but they don't ever say they won't
talk you don't need to know things about
the characters
just accept them
um all right let's keep playing i think
i thought of a good movie fight for
later well oh okay
when these fans are on the hunt the
pg-13 action is so mild they won't even
bother to show it
that's it but when these two pale boys
finally collide strap in for effects so
honest it looks like they added stink
lines to everyone to drive home how
crappy it looks
what were the lines what were the lines
yeah what are they representing him
it's one of those like trying to make it
look comic booky but they just don't
pull it off really because they're doing
that kind of bullety time thing when
they do it so i think it's supposed to
be like motion right it does make more
sense for like a like a wolf man or like
uh someone who uses their sense of smell
because it really did look like they
were just wafting their stank uh
everywhere they went there was a stank
waft yeah if it were bats it should be
like echoey and like
covered
yeah it looks a little bit like there's
like there's a cartoon pie in the
distance
by the delicious smell that would have
been great as if morbius to symbolize
when he was getting hungry if the other
person like turned into a large chicken
wing and then back into a person
so we would know as an audience guys
he's hot he's so hungry he wants to eat
them oh okay i get it
thank you goofy cartoons yeah don't like
it i already feel like i'm dying
i'm seeing the future baby let's go
marvel i'm on my second glass of the
success of no way home enjoy sony's
latest attempt to suck every last drop
of legally approved continuity from the
mcu like how about the daily bugle huh
that's the thing over there maybe it's
venom reference he's in both verses now
right well we haven't had anything this
good since that thing in san francisco
hey look it's the villain from two
spider-mans ago that doing anything for
you no
what if we put a gun to his head and
made him read a script from bryce over
in marketing i'm not sure how i got here
has to do with spider-man i think
i'm still figuring this place out but i
think a bunch of guys like us should
team up you know i never thought that
that was definitely recorded in like his
home oh my god he's in he's in his
closet in his family room right it was
such a the the post credits post post
credits yeah the first one well that
there's a mid credits and then the post
credits that's the post credits the mid
credits is just he appears in a jail
cell he's like
yeah
i'm in a different universe now and that
is up
there's a quick shot of him leaving
prison right quick out of that
it's up there with um
uh russell crowe uh describing the
monster the monsters the monsters
project in the mummy
or but that's at least in the middle of
the movie that's the most he interrupts
is it bvs or whatever where they have
the the file folder of the justice
league where they just are clicking from
person to person yes yes
such just like a
the studio said stop stop the movie stop
everything we're doing
you got to talk about the other thing
we're doing and it was the i think
that's the most egregious one i've ever
seen
this one yeah well the the fact that
first of all
like what do these two have to do with
each other why would they have no reason
to join forces they're not even working
on anything in particular that we know
about so it doesn't it doesn't mean
anything it's just like hey you're
you're kind of bad and i'm kind of
biased
i think i should work together together
but it's also it's just like his his
whole like starting with i don't know
why i'm even here i think it's got
something to do with spider-man it's
like you called this meeting what is
this meeting about
didn't even put this could have been
this this meeting could have been uh an
email yeah
how does he have his flight suit it does
yeah that because we see him materialize
from the other universe and he's just
he's in his shelf yeah
so he didn't he built a new vulture suit
got it yeah all right i guess that
that's that's the stuff left over from
the alien invasion
you know the alien invasion that didn't
happen
in this universe yeah brutal type um
but it's the implication is jared harris
is like raising those kids right not
just their doctor i thought yeah i was
like look after this one yeah i think
this i i agree with you viewers that
this is super muddled like i think he
does get out of a limo to get to the oh
does he okay and then i just missed it
it's possible they imply that well then
he would then there's your answer he's
not a comment he was a rich kid yeah
these are his parents
they're dead they're dead they're all
dead
they don't care uh no son of mine has
blood itis yeah right oh that's good
they disowned him because he has blood
items okay let's let's finish the
trailer
anna she's got my back could be topped
but bravo mr keaton bravo
starring
subway jared tyrese's police's
count white chocula
hi dr nick not another martine movie
i'm not sure how he got here has to do
with spider-man i think just turn this
place out but i think guys like them
should team up and when mom won't make
dendi's for dinner
i'm starting to get hungry
you don't want to see me when i'm hungry
bang bang
you know i hate to say it but w was way
ahead of the morbius thread tonight i
ask you to pass legislation to prohibit
the most egregious abuses of medical
research creating human animal hybrids
how did he know how did he know did he
no
it was an inside job
there are doctors
merging their dna with bats folks
it's a hellacious good time only in
theaters
they can see stink laughs
all right i've got a movie fight for you
guys um
oh play the thing
it's time for screen junkies movie
fights
all right
uh the question is this uh who would
last the longest against blade
morbius
uh twilight what's his name edward
evan from twilight
you know bruce from twilight
chad tyler edward cullen from twilight
or uh kirsten dunst interview with a
vampire
or name your own vampire
dunst
the child she's easy she's getting taken
out right away that's not i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go with our pats yeah you
think our pats would last the longest
yes yeah in a fight against blade
against blade i mean geez they're all
going out pretty easily well here's my
question does morbius ken is he the kind
of vampire that blabe specializes in
killing because he's a science vampire
not a catholic mythological vampire that
would be mine is there a difference okay
i mean i'm that's that i'm asking you
i'm asking blade i mean you think he
can't he can only handle one type of
vampire well i mean like blades got a
lot because we know that like some of
the rules like jared leto can walk
around sunlight and holy water doesn't
work on him so like i feel like a lot of
blades arsenal is really not geared
towards morbius as a threat and that was
exactly what i was thinking about edward
cullen because with edward cullen his
real super power is the power of being
freaking sexy that's true and so i do i
do think that what happens is is that
when um
they when when blade and blade and hot
man meet um
blade is so taken by how sparkly and
gorgeous it is that it's it becomes a
distraction and um everyone knows that
um edward cullen can read thoughts and
so he would be able to anticipate
blade's moves before they happen we also
know that he is the fastest of all of
the cullens
we also know that if it does come down
to a game of baseball cullens are going
to win they're going to win they're
going to take it
i'm going to i'm going to i'm going to
ride for uh kirsten dunst i think that
uh blade would not expect it i think
it's it's the last vampire you'd expect
and um i think that he'd have that kind
of like i can save her energy he'd be
like you know she's she's just a kid you
know maybe we could be like a lone wolf
and cub thing like i could i can i can
bring her over to the good side now he
straight up murdered his mom yeah
okay he killed kirsten that's all right
up all right well i think it's a
knockout uh edward
sorry morbo uh and sorry kirsten um all
right what do we do now we have some
delete yeah what do we do now
g fuel another round of g-fuel around
everyone fuel for the gang what's that
what's that right
the stuff in red oh i should open the
script g-fuel gifu g-fuel uh 3g fields
oh for people who are curious yes we
will be back to three plus three or more
probably three uh videos a week here
soon uh but the monday stream will not
uh be every week at 11 we will start
posting on the community yeah we're
redoing the schedule here we're adding
some new stuff subtracting some stuff
we're gonna figure it out and it'll all
be on the community tab to keep you
updated so if you're wondering why uh
we're not here also it's because there
hasn't been much news worth talking
about there's a new thor trailer should
we talk about that
sure yeah it looks good there you go
there's your monday show
hit the button right a great actor who
serves as a cautionary tale when you
wait too long to accept a marvel role
all that's left are the sony characters
marvel at the first studio tempo shot
entirely in liminal spaces from empty
freight vessels to empty tunnels to
empty labs to hospital rooms to other
hospital rooms in a film that responds
to the overuse of green screen by
throwing some junk in an apartment lobby
and calling it a money lab or something
i am going to need your laboratory just
leave the sciency stuff yeah pause story
so there's that moment where
he he meets back up with martine uh
who's like on the run or she is she's
not on the run she's like under
investigation yes um and he's on the run
and he meets up with her and it's like
this is a moment where martine could
like
you know help sneak him into a lab or
like be do something character related
have a purpose have a purpose in the
movie yeah and he's like just anything
he's like shut your mouth martina
i'm listening to some men talking behind
me and they're like we should go back to
our money lab to make more fake money
yeah he's like i could use that to build
to build vampire blood and he follows
them back there and yeah and breaks the
bones in their hands this is a movie
that saw the first doctor stranger was
like you know what would be great if
rachel mcadams had even less today yeah
let's make our movie but there's a
female character even more sidelined
truly nothing and then they they make
out they totally make out for like no
reason for zero reasons they they don't
have a lot of uh you know chemistry yeah
but they do make out it will be yeah
yeah they got to make the chemistry in a
lab
that's what the lab is for
well you have a fake lab all right keep
uh let's play this with starting stuff
30 seconds to moored it's morbid time
to be cast to be
useless vaulda dork doctor do
posh spice
the aristobat dr acula they went to
jared
inside of you are two jareds
drain and scully
i can't operate on him he's my son
darn it man i'm a doctor not a zoologist
the sinister sucks
blood murder test magic
this is morby us
brotherhood of the traveling bats
more bs
that's not the doctor
yes it is
how would you even know his name even
the people in his hometown don't know
who he is your costume is amazing thank
you one person
a great actor
i've used that line in stand up
thank you one person that that line is
is better than anything in mormon yeah
yeah that's the thing
is that this was like venom minus
anything weird or different like this is
the question we'll go into questions now
trevory says we're all going to crap on
morbius yes i hope we've done that yeah
but what's something good about it and
i'm struggling because
questions
that's what was missing yeah
obviously it's a fan questions
interstitial graphic yeah
could have really used that one yep um
yeah was it it did feel like venom like
a like a by the books kind of 90s era
comic book movie yes but venom had just
the weirdness of tom hardy unchained and
you've got to feel like jared leto
unchained can be weirder than this but
he took it he played it so kind of dry
yeah i think that he really was like i'm
going to do
something that feels very close and
personal to me yeah and it was michael
moore yes
you're doing a vampire movie it can be
camp like there was no camp yeah which
is wild and i i do wonder if it's one of
those things where he's like well you
know i went so far with joker i want to
make sure people know i'm not just one
note at these superhero movies i can
play the whole spectrum yeah i guess i i
don't know this to me it feels like the
good thing about this is they turned
what they had into a finished movie like
this feels like one of those this was so
troubled obviously went through so many
variations on its way to the screen it
feels like the victory is that it exists
like it came out there's a movie you can
watch it it's called morbius it looks
like a movie
it feels relatively like a movie like
that's the win
it doesn't always work out that way and
you know like i i think that the fact
that they pulled it through it's almost
hard to evaluate as a move because
almost nothing we're seeing is like what
it was supposed to be yeah i have a good
one um it is roughly 90 minutes long oh
yeah yeah you appreciate that appreciate
it when you're watching some of these
yeah i mean most of it's skipping a lot
of it's crazy yeah
all right evan j pretzel asks uh is the
sinister six movie something sony is
going to ram through at this point i
mean yeah because we're getting uh
craven the hunter that's that's a real
one um they're definitely do we've got
venom we've got we've been morbed um i
see
vultures there now like they're doing
the legwork of consolidating their
villains in one universe which
i feel like the reason you do that is
because you want to get them all in one
thing yeah
again son spider-man or or no
i mean i i think i think to personally i
think that their their secret plan is
garfield like wait till andrew
garfield's ready to cut because he's on
a little you know hiatus from acting or
whatever he's really made of a million
movies in the last two years under the
banner of heaven on hulu right now check
it out folks but like again it is pretty
good but uh like i feel like when he's
ready to come back that's what it seems
obvious that that's what you do you have
a parallel spider-man franchise yeah
garfield's your spider-man you got all
of his villains ready to go i mean the
answer is yeah of course what else does
until sony gets something else to work
it's all it's the spider-man company
yeah the spider-man company and video
games jumanji jumanji spiderman
ghostbusters
men in black coming back any decade now
uh i'll figure that out we'll end with
this uh arthur bingo s uh when we finish
our pre-workout how do we all plan on
burning off oh my god i'm gonna run home
i could run home right now yeah i could
run him i live like nine miles away and
yeah
it's far but i feel like i could
probably do it
uh yeah i think i'm just gonna start
doing that like a milo dance
there you go yeah
yeah um uh find me on on steam uh
kingspen i will be uh headshotting from
now until hours of the evening i'm just
gonna be in the game zone yeah yeah just
just strap me in um
good times uh
we are gonna we're we're gonna run home
pretty fast but not as fast as next
week's honest trailer that's your clue
[Music]
oh thank you thank you
uh glad i got it right this time yeah um
they'll be excited to ring it in with us
yeah always a pleasure uh this has been
eventful hopefully we'll have another
themed beverage or just keep drinking
morbius morby is cooler every time here
on honest trailer commentaries we'll see
you next week bye
[Music]
bear